people will say i'm not flexible enough
to do yoga
i'm too old to do yoga i'm not healthy
enough to do yoga but really if you have
a body and you can breathe you can do
yoga
and just by regulating the breath
someone can have a profound
experience of yoga in their very first
class
but that 15 minutes you spent
nourishing yourself means that when you
go back to your family
or you go back into your work situation
you have something to offer
in this master class you're getting
something basic
yet very essential to your understanding
of what yoga
is i'll be demonstrating
the simplest practices to more advanced
versions of those practices
so this is a really wonderful way of
breathing
if you're anxious if you're feeling
emotional
tension purse the limbs making a sound
whoo you may want to add imagery
that you have a candle in front of you
you're making it so
gentle so soft that the candle doesn't
flicker
or go out
your life as we know it can change
in an instant three years ago
i had a serious accident i've been using
yoga to restore my body
first two years was mostly about
learning how to walk again
i'm witnessing quite a miraculous
restoration
we may move through some real storms in
our life
thank goodness i've had yoga to find
some part of myself that is unshakable
pristine
could never be damaged that's really the
focus of the practice
to find the part of ourselves that is
always steady
i'm donna fari and this is my master
class
[Music]
you